but her lack of professionalism and poor
judgment in delegating the
responsibilities to others appears to
have significantly contributed to her
calling below the standards of care
Stern words from Dr Jonathan B Fable
just one member of the 12-member board
tasked with investigating complaints and
issuing or in this case revoking license
as deemed fit
Dr Robinson claims that this will change
her life forever
or she has single-handedly forever
changed lives of at least three people
it was the concerns of not meeting the
standard of care that brought the
physician to this point as early as 2018
Dr groy was asked to address concerns of
patient privacy on social media the
plastic surgeon often posted behind the
scenes video often shot in an operating
room the board also sent notice to the
surgeon explaining three patients
treated from 2020 to 2022 were treated
inappropriately or given in proper
discharge papers those concerns plus
others including a Recovery House run by
the surgeon not staffed by medical
professionals and surgeries performed in
an office setting without the proper
licensure were all evaluated by the
board and sometimes I did silly or fun
videos simply to make people smile in
this world which is often negative and
difficult that's not your job your job
is to care for people okay
that's not your job boo
that's not your job
when you when you're on the job and you
have peoples live in your hands focus on
that
we'll let other people
in the circles do that let the comedians
do that that's not your job no no no
what the hell
I didn't send anybody else while I was
doing that with your dirty ass phone and
For the First Time The Physician spoke
publicly calling the initial suspension
humbling and pleading for another chance
but for former patients at the hearing
the police simply wasn't enough former
patient Mary Jenkins won a civil case
against the former doctor she says the
license revocation is in a sense closure
but as the damage she and so many other
women live with will never go away it'll
never go away because every time we look
down and we see a scar we're going to
remember so what is the extent of what
you actually did
just a very valid question let's look it
up what the [__] is going on it's kind
of also like you don't want to look away
because you're like oh my God what's
going to happen like how did this so
this is uh Cassandra Banks and who did
the extensive research on the topic so
let's take a look a Tick-Tock doctor had
her medical license suspended for
alleged botched surgeries live streaming
procedures on Tick Tock potentially
without patient permission and telling
those patients not to call 9-1-1 if they
had medical complications yeah Dr Roxy
also known as Dr grah is a plastic
surgeon from Ohio she had 850 000
followers on Tick Tock and I think 130
something thousand on Instagram and
although she grew up in San Diego
California she went to medical school in
2005 when she became a doctor and just
because you're a doctor doesn't mean
that you're a plastic surgeon or that
you have specialized in anything so she
went through what appears to be an extra
five years of training to become a
plastic surgeon and she's actually been
a plastic surgeon and operated her own
Clinic called The Roxy Clinic where
people could get a foxy Roxy body which
she's done for the past 13 years
um let me get a number two in the foxy
Roxy body thank you ah super sausage
titties and the ass for me thank you I
mean it's America The Landing yeah yeah
but it's it's just funny for me it's
just funny
a mommy makeover yeah with a Diet Coke
please
they try to make everything sound cute
and sexy to remove the stigma of surgery
well Tick Tock has not been around for
13 years but it has been around for a
little bit more than three and
apparently ever since 2020 Dr Roxy has
not only been posting online but
actually getting in trouble for it and
although everyone's reporting on this I
was like a tick tock surgery disaster
there's a lot [__] is passed out
in the back probably didn't consent to
that so you see the vitals of the person
although the person look dead the person
is live and alive it's so it's
we're losing the patient we just have to
go for two seconds that's just crazy and
we're not just talking about the surface
of the skin
now when anyone has been in practice for
13 years there's bound to be
complications right human bodies are
complex the complications here have
gotten real bad and the alleged
potential cover-ups and the potential
lack of post-procedure or after
procedure care that patients have
allegedly not been given it's led to
three lawsuits this winter alone and yes
she did just get her MD or her medical
license revoked now when it comes to
tick tock a lot of doctors and
dermatologists and estheticians and care
providers are using social media almost
as a resume there are some very
interesting data on how social media is
the new resume social media is an
intrinsic part of our life time she was
promoting plastic surgery unnecessarily
such as doing this pencil test with the
the cleavages and I will actually link
to this in the description if you want
to see it Miss pencil test I don't know
if it's something she created or not but
she was basically telling women if you
don't pass this test with a pencil you
have to come get plastic surgery which
is not an ethical way to do Marketing in
my personal opinion but it's not just my
opinion here because apparently the
medical board agreed the State Medical
Board suspended her license on November
18th and they actually saw a lot of
issues both with what she was posting on
social media as well as some of the
botched surgeries and complaints that
people were having she claims that her
approach to plastic surgery was
different she had an all-female staff
and she claimed that it was quote like a
spa when people came to get things like
a tummy tuck or a boob job or even yes
Brazilian butt lifts which her Clinic
offered but she also had a unique
approach to her Aftercare she basically
had like a Roxy Clinic she called her
followers her foxies and people who
would come get these procedures would
actually stay in like a house or
um hi foxies
that is weird My Guy
this video is brought to you by surf
shark stop what you're doing right now
it's a quick reminder you need surf
shark in your life why well super shark
is a VPN changer if you're using public
Wi-Fi public Wi-Fi is actually filthy
because all the information is not
encrypted if you have a third shark it
encrypts the information for you so that
if you do a transaction it's safer not
only that it comes with an antivirus do
you know that surf shark is the only VPN
changer that sure there's no limits in
the devices yeah if you have three
phones one subscription boom three
phones why would you have three phones I
don't know that's your business though
and if you click on the link below right
now click on the link you've called
promo code Alma and preach you're gonna
be able to have on top of your
subscription three months for free
uh-huh and there's a 30-day money-back
warranty get yourself uh a VPN changer
to be a little bit more safe
because you're on the public Wi-Fi right
now
and that [__] is filthy
oh
the things that people do on the public
Wi-Fi or a location where they were
covered think of like the Dr Phil house
but for Brazilian butt lift recovery
surgery now some of the main issues were
what actually happened in those recovery
clinics or what didn't happen after
those surgeries and what was posted on
social media part of the time without
permission or without even paying
attention to what was going on now
please keep in mind that all of this is
alleged everyone is innocent until
proven guilty and there are some that
are speaking up and posting on Tick Tock
and vocal about it and others that are
staying silent essentially multiple
people started filing complaints from
botched surgeries infections things not
healing properly having bad reactions
and not getting discharge paper or
basically the what you're supposed to do
after this treatment sort of papers that
are medically required to provide and
some people were even told not to call
9-1-1 there was specifically this woman
who posted her story on Tick Tock saying
that she went to Dr Roxy because she was
so excited and found her on social media
but then her tummy tuck as a new mom was
botched and now she's having to have a
corrected surgery and it hurts for her
to even stand another person had bowel
perforation from liposuction which is
not only horrible and has the potential
to cause major infection and
complications yes there's always risks
when it comes to liposuction out of all
of the procedures that plastic surgeons
do liposuction is known to be one of the
safer ones and the fact that liposuction
actually put holes into someone's
intestines that's you gotta that's kind
of hard to do which we're gonna talk
about exactly how that happens but when
you look at some of these videos that
were posted online of Dr Roxy like not
even paying attention to the camera as a
viewer of this who's just watching this
objectively and again that
watching the camera while you have a
whole tubing something nah be your foul
for this [__] okay you go into details
if you guys want to look up more
Cassandra Banks and does a good video on
the topic but you guys go check out the
tick tocks themselves awesomeness social
media is a hell of a drug and the way
it's got some of y'all in its grips
goddamn this woman threw away her a
whole [__] career as a doctor
for likes actually you know what I need
to stop saying that because like
Cassandra was saying social media really
do be these doctor's resumes how they
expand their clinics how they find a lot
of their clients I think it's like here
in Canada it's unethical
for clinics uh and doctors to Market
themselves privately the reason being is
because when they're going on social
media and they're doing all these posts
and stuff like that they constantly try
to find ways to make things more
appealing less medical less this less
that and just trying to Garner as many
people through the doors which leads to
really shoddy marketing tactics all
right to the point where it stops being
about a medical practice and how you can
make it look cool and glamorous rather
than making the procedure really good
um which when I see stuff like this I
understand why they have these laws in
practices here in Ken and I prefer it
that way personally sometimes I see some
medical professionals or counselors or
psychologists that are online and you
see these people giving asinine
diagnoses or just really weird stuff
because it's appealing on social media
or it's garnering them views and you
have to think that they're using their
position of authority the board
certified certificates that they're
given to be able to Garner the attention
of so many people right people are
watching not because this person's
interesting but because doctor is
watching or reacting to a situation
right so
you know these titles come with a
tremendous amount of power and sometimes
the way that they wield their social
media accounts it doesn't seem like they
wield that power with any responsibility
so uh yeah me watching some of this
stuff I just I think it's very
disappointing but
I want to ask you what do you think is
watching all this
well you said most of it you know it's
crazy how social media got us I think
it's a bit different in the states that
it is in Canada
but still I see it still see it here a
bit to be able to promote people and
people are watching a lot yeah social
media is very much the resume of a lot
of people you know I mean for a lot of
things not just for jobs just for you
know when you try to meet someone trying
to meet someone you're going to try to
look at the social media to see what
kind of thing they post if it's too
cringe you probably go to dash that away
because I understand but they do that
for work and stuff like that so for
tattoo artists I can understand for
certain things I can on medical when you
have the lives of people in your hands I
don't know it's a bit weird it could be
a yo super weird
calling people at the marketing behind
it is super weird like you're ordering
something
foxy Roxy body hi everybody
um
just wanted to give everybody
like what update is what's going on so
um
I went in ER on Friday and
um today is Sunday and I'm still here
I have lost track on how many IB
antibiotics that I've given
but I have
definite infection
um I know one is a stab infection and
there's another one I'm not too sure
what it's called but um
supposed to see an infectious disease
doctor
today
um so
uh
just try to get through this
um
and then probably lose my job about this
no
don't know what I'm gonna do
for money
um
but it is what it is and I will get
through this
um
at this point I just want to be home
like my children and my family and so
I appreciate everybody's positive
thoughts
um
so sorry for me looking disastrous
um but just please continue to
um
prayers and everything else and um
try to share this as much as possible so
hopefully more people come forward
um because this is not okay
um she's basically flipped my life
upside down
um
pretty much go
hopefully not but
possibly losing my job
um
the mental
stress
that I've gone through so
um
being away from my family
is real people affected by this kind of
stuff yeah
you know so it's one thing if uh
you're making burgers and you want to be
on tick tock
it's a different thing if you're an open
heart surgeon you're like all right so
let's level to this [__] there's levels
to this [__] definitely yeah me you want
to dance and flip Burgers but you want
to have people's life in your hand if
you're bigger it's like a cop it's just
like a cop if the cop is just on the job
I'm like oh look at me I arrested this
Baddie I can't take you seriously okay
uh
anyways whatever
hey man
the reasoning I can't get over it the
reasoning why you made you yeah
like you're making a milkshake or some
[__] uh the reasoning of why you were
making those videos as well is super
lame super lame
super lame you're not [__] Taylor
Swift you know shake it off like what
are you doing what are you doing
so you're disconnected at this point in
this world that we live in I just want
to make fun cute videos to me that's not
your job boo-boo Oh my days you said to
yourself ah it'd be a good idea oh let
me be on the wheel of a city bus right
but in the same time I want to Enlighten
everybody's moves I'm gonna make Tick
Tock dance while I'm gonna be behind the
wheel the [__] is wrong with you drive
your bus stupid there's other people
there's traffic you got to be attentive
there's cyclist yo
disconnected disconnected
but whatever
you lost your license you should have
gone to jail
you lost your license I think you got
off easy My Girl you lost your license
you should have gone to jail yeah you
fly you altered the lives of so many
people like jail absolutely jail it is
actually crazy how many professionals be
it cops this kind of [__] are able to
escape like real punishment jail and
it's fast
Jam
I want like 60 60 days they got to do
jail from home what the [__] is Jeff
from home said Baldur's Gate just came
out I'm about to be playing that [__]
all day you know what I mean like yo
I don't know it's just it's interesting
watching this now paid leave [__] out of
here because I'm realizing just how sick
some of this [__] is in terms of
attention seeking it's really a city you
should you should you shouldn't you
should have been to in prison yes you
should have been in prison 100 my girl
Hey listen class
y sickness of the highest order and we
do not want it
deviants therefore we don't want it
there you go anything else
we're not done with this one she has
decided to call herself a doctor
but we have to ask who has asked for her
the wrong people they went in for a
tummy tuck now they look like a snowman
I feel bad for them they are melting
every day
my friend you wanted to go for breast
implants now you have triangles for
titties
I feel bad for you you have a pizza
slice one pepperoni
get the [__] out of here cut this [__]
out
no this one
cut this [__] off go cut this [__] out
you fell for this [__] you fell you
hella foul yes but y'all laughing
it is a good one huh
this one I got from my uncle when he is
going to the whorehouse he said this one
had it pizza pizza pizza pizza breasts
one pepperoni pepperoni
Dr Roxy if you are watching this one
this time we are going to pay our tax if
you don't you're going to jail
he should have gone to jail girl yes I
agree
I agree someday have a good day
goodbye